eine Familie machte Deutschland mobil
am Anfang des 20 Jahrhunderts schufen
die Opels das erste volks-auto damit
wurde aus einem Luxusgut ein
alltägliches Fortbewegungsmittel fünf
Brüder revolutionierten mit dieser Idee
das Land wenn ein Opel was machen möchte
dann macht das auch und setzt dann auch
alles dran und durch dass er sein Ziel
erreicht
für ihre Ziele setzen sie auch schon mal
ihr Leben aufs Spiel
sie erschufen das größte deutsche
Autowerk ihre Zeit
und veränderten damit die Gesellschaft
das Werk machte sie reich und
ermöglichte ihnen ein Leben auf der
Überholspur
[Musik]
11 märz 1964 der Julia Pass in der
Schweiz
der Tag der die Familie Opel für immer
verändern wird
es ist ausgerechnet ein Unfall mit einem
Auto an dem die Familie zu zerbrechen
droht das Automobil hatte die Familie
Ernst reich gemacht und wurde zugleich
ihr Fluch
die Opels
der großen Familie gelang in kurzer Zeit
ein märchenhafter Aufstieg mit ihren
Ideen hat sie das Leben der Deutschen
für immer verändert
der bekannteste Spross der Familie war
Gunter Sachs
die Opels zählten zu den neuen reichsten
Familien Deutschlands doch ihr Reichtum
und Erfolg entscheiden die Familie
Fritz von Opel hätte die Firma einst
führen sollen doch er stand in einem
Konkurrenzkampf mit seinem Cousin Georg
von Opel der Wettstreit hatte Folgen für
die Familie und das Werk zwei starke
Jungs fast gleich alt eine halbe
Generation verschoben 99
1912 aber zwei Typen da geht's natürlich
auch drum wer ist der bessere wer hat
mehr Glück und da haben sie sich in ganz
vielen Dingen gemessen
die Opel Werke in Rüsselsheim noch heute
steht vor dem Haupteingang die Büste von
Adam Opel nach ihm wurde das Werk
benannt
doch Adam Opel hat nie ein einziges Auto
gebaut
Ende des 19 Jahrhunderts macht er sich
als erfolgreicher Unternehmer einen
Namen erbaut Nähmaschinen
[Musik]
und Fahrräder
Adam Opel hat fünf Söhne und die Träumen
heimlich von etwas anderem etwas
aufregenderem schnelleren
1885 hat im Namen Mannheim Carl Benz das
Automobil erfunden und es ist Wilhelm
der seinen Vater bekniet das Opel auch
Autos bauen soll doch Adam Opel will
nicht diese stinkkutschen aus denen wird
nie mehr als Spielzeug für Millionäre
das erste Auto das carl-benz verkauft
hat ging dann einen Mann der
anschließend nachgewiesenermaßen in der
Irrenanstalt endete und die ganzen Leute
drumherum haben gesagt ja klar sowas
kann nur ein Irrer kaufen so war es am
Anfang doch dann halt die Familie 1895
ein Schicksalsschlag Adam Opel stirbt an
Typhus er wird nur 59 Jahre alt
durch den Tod des Vaters wird der Weg
frei für Wilhelm den Sohn
1899 bauen die Opels ihren ersten Wagen
sie achten auf höchstem Komfort und ein
ausgefeiltes Sicherheitskonzept der
Wagen besitzt sogar ein Seitenlicht
[Musik]
doch die Opels müssen viel investieren
damals ist Autobau Handarbeit jedes Auto
ist ein Unikat ein Kunstwerk 40 Autos
bauen sie so im Jahr das Auto ist nur
ein Spielzeug für reiche Leute
die Produktion frisst die Ersparnisse
der Familie auf die Firma hängt an einem
seidenen Faden beim Opels war es oft
auch vor Tönen was mit geschminkt hat
als nicht immer nur Fleiß und Talent
sondern auch
besonders bei den Opels war es viel
Glück was zu dem gesamt Erfolg bei Druck
mit Autorennen versuchen die Opels Ihr
Produkt bekannt zu machen es ist ein
waghalsiges Unterfangen in die Rennen
gehen nicht selten tödlich aus
doch sie locken Zuschauer und damit
mögliche Kundschaft
1907 kommt sogar der Kaiser zu einem
internationalen Rennen und die Opels
erreichen als erstes deutsches Team das
Ziel
der Kaiser ist begeistert und übergibt
den Siegerpokal
aber nicht nur das Seine Majestät wollen
jetzt auch einen Opel
das andere vernünftiger Kaiser
der hat gewusst was gut ist dich über
aber wenigstens da der gewusst was gut
ist
Wilhelm Opel ist jetzt Hoflieferant er
trägt die kaiserliche Uniform
unermüdlich treibt er nun seine Firma an
er will mehr erreichen
seinen Ehrgeiz gibt er weiter an seine
Kinder und Tochter Elinor und vor allem
an Sohn Fritz ihm impft er ein was es
heißt ein Opel zu sein die Opel Mania
ist Dinge bis nach Ende zu bringen und
die wollen Sieger sein die wollen die
ersten sein das geht nicht dass die die
zweiten sind mehr schneller höher dieser
Rausch das ist für mich das eigentliche
was die Familie
hochgebracht hat wie ein Komet sozusagen
dass sie in kurzer Zeit so viel
erreichen konnten
doch der Aufstieg wird je gestoppt der
Erste Weltkrieg trifft die Firma schwer
die Arbeiter müssen an die Front
die Produktion in Rüsselsheim kann nur
mit Frauen und Kriegsgefangenen aufrecht
erhalten werden und die Familie trifft
das Schicksal hart
[Musik]
Ludwig Opel der jüngste Bruder von
Wilhelm fällt an der Front
da ist es nur ein schwacher Trost für
die Familie dass die Opels für ihre
Pionierarbeit für das Automobil ein Jahr
später geadelt werden
die Brüder gehen schwierigen Zeiten
entgegen der Krieg geht verloren
aufgrund der Inflation kommt die
Produktion nahezu zum Erliegen niemand
mehr kann sich die teuren Autos leisten
die Opels sind verzweifelt sie müssen
etwas ändern radikal und sie sind dazu
bereit
Risiko
spielt eine sehr große Rolle und
das haben meine Vorfahren auch immer
bewiesen also die haben ja kein Risiko
gescheut neue Dinge auszuprobieren um
die Firma zu retten kommen die Opels auf
einer einfache wie geniale Idee sie
produzieren keine Luxusautos mehr nun
wollen sie einen kostengünstigen
Kleinwagen bauen und entwickeln einen
Prototypen einen Zweisitzer mit
Bootsheck der wegen seiner grünen
Lackierung auch Laubfrosch genannt wird
doch dann wäre Skandal
citroën hatte bereits vorher einen Wagen
gebaut der exakt genauso aussah wurde
Zitrone genannt weil er gelb lackiert
war
die Franzosen werfen nun Opel vor sie
hätten unerlaubt kopiert und strengen
einen Prozess an vor dem
Reichskammergericht in Berlin kommt es
zu einem erbitterten Streit die
Franzosen sind außer sich
in vielen Punkten
das weiß man mittlerweile auch ist man
mittlerweile auch bei Opel selbst
bereits zuzugeben also etante von mir
die Therese Weber eine sehr resolute
Dame die wohnte also auch da in der Nähe
Mönchhof und die hat immer erzählt
einmal Bruder der anne und ich wir haben
auf dem Werksgelände immer gespielt und
habe doch genau gewusst wo der Citroën
versteckt ist das Gericht entscheidet
kein Plagiat der Citroen sei gelb und
der Opel grün lackiert damit wäre jede
Verwechslungsgefahr ausgeschlossen
nur wenige Jahre nach dem verlorenen
Krieg herrscht in der deutschen Justiz
noch keine franzosenfreundliche Stimmung
im Volksmund entsteht daraus der Spruch
das gleiche in Grün der Ball den ganzen
Deutschen Reich zur Redewendung wird
Glück für Wilhelm von Opel er kann jetzt
den Laubfrosch produzieren um ihn aber
so billig wie möglich zu Bauen setzt
Wilhelm auf eine völlig neuartige
Methode
die Idee
und hat gesehen dass ich sein Produktion
dort gemacht wird und Amerika war damals
schon fortschrittlich in der Produktion
und da hat man hingeschaut und die Söhne
haben sich das mal durchgerechnet und
haben gesehen dass das einen großen
Vorteil bringen würde und waren die
ersten die das dann in Deutschland
umgesetzt haben mit großen Erfolg
1924 führt Opel als erstes Werk in
Deutschland die Fließbandarbeit ein
Wilhelm revolutioniert damit das
Arbeitsleben der deutschen die
Produktivität wird gewissermaßen
erzwungen im Tank des Fließbandes
1924 gab es noch Startprobleme es gab
natürlich dann auch die Panne dass man
nicht bedacht hat dass das menschliche
Bedürfnis die Menschen manchmal vom
Arbeitsplatz abruft die Tätigkeit wird
auf wenige Handgriffe reduziert
schon 1924 warnen Kritiker vor
Entfremdung und Abstumpfung der Arbeiter
heute sehen die Opels die damalige
Einführung des Fließbandes zwiespältig
es gab eine ganz andere Denkweise man
war eben Bandarbeiter
man war eben nicht mit der
Automobilbauer das kann man eigentlich
sicherstellen der Leute kann man das
erkennen wenn die fotografiert werden
das selbstbewusste ist nicht mehr so
vorhanden wie das vorher war
[Musik]
aus meiner Sicht hat das liest man
natürlich nur Vorteile gebracht die
Arbeitsabläufe wurden wesentlich
schneller das Auto konnte schneller
fertiggestellt werden und das war der
Durchbruch
günstig produzieren zu können und das
Automobil für die breite Bevölkerung zur
Verfügung stellen zu können
die Opels legen den Grundstein für die
Massenmobilität
die Pferde haben ausgedient
alles ändert sich Tankstellen entstehen
Straßen werden gebaut immer größere
Entfernungen können zurückgelegt werden
das Leben der Menschen verändert sich
die Mobilität hat ich glaube in den in
den Hirnen
dramatische Veränderungen
hervorgerufen weil das sind ja alles
Wünsche das sind ja alles Träume die
früher nicht existent waren weil sie
nicht erfüllbar waren
und ich glaube das ist eines der großen
geheime des Automobils und das ist die
Verführbarkeit des Automobils dass es in
der Lage ist
Träume zu realisieren dass diese Träume
mit Albträumen mittlerweile teilweise
verbunden sind ist die Kehrseite
[Musik]
es ist eine Revolution die von Opel
angestoßen wurde das Werk ist Mitte der
20er Jahre die größte und modernste
deutsche Automobilfabrik
Wilhelm von Opel will seine neue Macht
sichern
seine Tochter Elinor wird mit nur 17
Jahren verheiratet mit dem industriellen
Sohn Willi Sachs es ist eine Zwecke
die Sachs produzieren Kugel Lager und
die kann Wilhelm gut gebrauchen für das
Werk das einmal seinen Sohn Fritz
übernehmen möchte
Fritz von Opel träumt davon bald die
Firma zu führen doch der Erwartungsdruck
des Vaters lastet schwer auf ihm
er war nach außen hin war er schon stark
nach ihnen das bekam man nicht so mit
war er unsicher sensibel hat sich gerne
auch in Gedichte schreibend und lesend
hinein versponnen war zweifelnder als
man denkt weil er nach außen hin ein
tolles auftreten hatte der Sportsmann
der der Charmeur
Fritz von Opel fährt wie sein Vater
früher Rennen und die sehr erfolgreich
doch es langt nicht automatisch die
Nummer eins in der Nachfolge zu sein
denn er hat einen Konkurrenten seinen
Cousin Georg von Opel
auch Georg ist sportlich zu dem
technisch begabt und ehrgeizig schon
früh arbeitet er in der Firma mit 16 ist
er noch zu jung und zu verspielt um sich
direkt für die Nachfolge zu empfehlen
trotzdem bleibt er eine Konkurrenz für
seinen Cousin Fritz der weiß nur der
erste zählt bei den Opels und er will
erster bleiben und das vermag
wahrscheinlich auch so die gewisse
Risikobereitschaft bei Fritz von Opel
geweckt zu haben dass man halt schon
auch versucht hat innerhalb der Familie
innerhalb dieses engsten Kreises
herauszustechen und was besonderes zu
leisten
Fritz von Opel führt öffentlich riskante
Kunststücke vor er will zeigen dass er
in der Lage ist aus einem fahrenden
Motorboot in ein Flugzeug umzusteigen
am 23 mai 1928 präsentiert er in Berlin
eine Sensation ein Raketenauto das mit
120 Kilogramm Dynamit angetrieben wird
er will einen Geschwindigkeitsrekord
aufstellen und der schnellste Mann der
Welt sein
von 0 auf 100 in 80 Sekunden
238 Stundenkilometer schnell
also dass er jedes Mal mit seinem Leben
spielte mit 120 Kilo Sprengstoff unter
sich das ist höchstes Risiko wo man
eigentlich sagen müsste grenzwertig fast
wahnsinnig
doch Fritz macht weiter im Sommer 1928
installiert er bei einem weiteren Test
375 Kilogramm Sprengstoff er will aber
zunächst einen unbemannten Versuch
starten und steigt nicht ein
das rettet ihm das Leben
trotzdem will Fritz von Opel weiter
experimentieren
[Musik]
für das Werk in Rüsselsheim hat das
Verhalten des jungen Opel dramatische
Auswirkungen
[Musik]
Wilhelm von Opel trifft eine wichtige
Entscheidung er will sein Lebenswerk
verkaufen
bisher wurden immer nur wirtschaftliche
Gründe für diesen Schritt vermutet zum
ersten Mal spricht die Familie über den
eigentlichen Grund es war kein
Nachfolger da eben nur den Fritz den
Fritz von Opel und naja
können wir das sehen bis zutrauen einem
dem Raketen fliegt und mit Raketen fährt
und der alles mögliche macht können wir
dem dieses große Werk übergeben das war
sicherlich nicht so das Wilhelm von Opel
nicht überzeugt war von den Fähigkeiten
seines Sohnes
seines halsbrecherischen Sohnes jetzt in
diesem Sinne im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes und aus diesem Grund auch sich
überlegt die Firma zu verkaufen
der Verkauf hat Auswirkungen auf das
weitere Leben des Sohnes der vom Vater
übergangen wird
für Fritz von Opel war der Verkauf der
Firma ein sehr großer Schlag ja
1929 geschah das sehr sehr schnell ohne
dass er wirklich ein zutun hatte oder
überhaupt davon wusste
dass dort plötzlich seine Lebensaufgabe
weg war hat ihn sicherlich erbittert und
hat ihn für sein Leben stark gebrochen
[Musik]
nach außen schweigt sich die Familie
damals über den wahren Grund des
Verkaufs aus die deutsche Öffentlichkeit
ist fassungslos für sie ist es
vaterlandsverrat
denn das Werk wird an Amerikaner
verkauft
[Musik]
der neue Herr aus Detroit Alfred Sloan
der Manager von General Motors
er will den deutschen Automarkt erobern
doch die öffentliche Stimmung ist gegen
ihn er ist Ausländer
um der Bevölkerung deutsche Kontinuität
vorzutäuschen wird der Kreise Wilhelm
von Opel als Aufsichtsratsvorsitzender
installiert
[Musik]
es ist eine schwere Aufgabe denn in
Deutschland haben die Nazis die Macht
übernommen und wollen die Wirtschaft für
ihre Zwecke einspannen
[Musik]
Wilhelm soll auch bei den Nazis für
Vertrauen Sorgen denn die haben Großes
vor mit der Automobilindustrie
auf der allmähliche Änderung der
Einstellung des deutschen Volkes dem
Kraftwagen gegenüber entstand ein
steigendes Interesse an all dem was mit
dem Kraftwagen oder Motorisierung
zusammenhängt das deutsche Volk ist
deshalb heute nicht nur in seine
Gesetzgebung sondern auch seine
Gesamteinstellung Kraftwagen freundlich
geworden
Hitler fordert den Volkswagen
auf der Berliner Auto schauen 1936 will
er die Entscheidung treffen wer ihn
bauen soll
opel hat einen hartnäckigen
konkurrenzten Ferdinand Porsche und
Hitler misstraut den Amerikanern Wilhelm
von Opel soll es richten und den Auftrag
sichern er begrüßte dann aber den Adolf
Hitler mit Heil Hitler Herr Hitler gab
ihm sogar die Hand die bürgerlich ein
Fehler hast es mit Namen anspricht er
will mein Führer genannt werden eisiges
Schweigen am Opel stand Hitler kocht
innerlich vor Wut nach einer Minute geht
er wieder ohne das Auto näher betrachtet
zu haben wenige Tage später gibt er
Ferdinand Porsche den Auftrag für den
Volkswagen
wer lässt sich mit dem Führer feiern
Opel geht ein Millionengeschäft verloren
Wilhelm von Opel hat es verbockt ja was
heißt verbockt hätte gesagt mein Führer
Unheil Hitler und von untertänigst
ihr hoffentlich künftiger Lieferant was
mit mir dann heute sagen er hat also mit
Sicherheit nicht bewusst versucht
provokant zu sein
ich denke
er hat einfach gar nicht drüber
nachgedacht er hat versucht sich gut zu
benehmen und hat es aber halt vollkommen
falsch gemacht
Wilhelms Schwiegersohn Willi Sachs zeigt
wie man es richtig macht auch der
präsentiert dem Führer seine neuesten
Produkte
wie die Sachs kann gut mit den führenden
Nazis besonders gut mit Heinrich Himmler
beide treffen sich wiederholt auch
privat
als Willi Sachs das Ehepaar Himmler
einladen will kommt es zu einem Eklat
mit seiner Ehefrau ellino
[Musik]
ja sie mochte alle Leute die irgendwo in
der Parteien aber waren nicht besonders
und sicherlich auch nicht die
Führungskräfte und äh wie das Ehepaar
Himmler kommen sollte sagte sie diese
Putzfrau kommt mir nicht ins Haus die
Ehe zerbricht Walter rauf er denn nur
flüchtet mit ihren Söhnen Ernst Wilhelm
und Gunter Sachs in die Schweiz
der erzählte Gatte bittet seinen Freund
Himmel um Hilfe zusammen mit Reinhard
Heidrich legt der SS-Führer des Jesus
über Elinor an er lässt sie beobachten
um seinem Freund wie die Sachs zu helfen
denn die SS hat einen perfiden Plan
sie will die Kinder entführen der kleine
Gunter Sachs soll heim ins Reich
gebracht werden
Himmler und Heidrich schicken vier
SS-Männer in die Schweiz
sie bringen die Kinder zunächst in ihre
Gewalt doch die Schweizer Polizei kann
sie wieder befreien was dem kleinen
Gunter Sachs bleibt ist Angst
[Musik]
mein Vater hatte ganz klar Erinnerungen
dass eben quasi sie zu Hause bleiben
sollten und nicht mehr raus sollten und
mit niemandem sprechen und so weiter
also das weiß ich das hatte noch hatte
noch ganz klar gesagt
bis zum Kriegsende 45 fürchten sie sich
vor weiteren Attacken der es ist es ist
eine klaustrophobische Erfahrung die den
Heranwachsenden Gunter Sachs für sein
Leben prägt mein Vater war ein starker
Individualist und er hatte auch eine
charakterliche Großzügigkeit die auch
dorthin ging leben und leben lassen so
wie auch leben wollte
ja also diesen großen Drang irgendwo zur
Freiheit
nur 30 Jahre bauten die Opels Autos in
Rüsselsheim das Werk veränderte
Deutschland aber das Werk verändert er
auch die Familie
1948 stirbt Wilhelm von Opel er hatte
das Werk aufgebaut und verkauft
bestattet wird er im Opel Mausoleum in
Rüsselsheim das direkt am Werk steht
der Verkauf der Firma hatte die Familie
reich gemacht und stellte sie jetzt vor
neue Herausforderungen
[Musik]
die Aufgabe das Auto war weg stattdessen
war Geld da und man musste selbst
anfangen ob als Elternteil oder als
begünstigtes Kind was daraus zu machen
das ja furchtbar schwer wenn man es
nicht gelernt hat wenn man schon heiß
gebadet aufgewachsen ist und dann
was Neues erfinden muss ist
schwierig
die Familie ist groß und jeder wählt
einen anderen Weg
Gunter sagst der sich immer auch als
Opel empfindet und sich zeitweise Gunter
Sachs von Opel nennt nutzt den Reichtum
auf seiner Art und wird der erste
bekannte deutsche Playboy
[Musik]
er hatte ja eine unwahrscheinliche
Ausstrahlung eine Aura möchte man fast
sagen die man gespürt hat wenn man in
seiner Nähe war
das war etwas fast überirdisches
sprechen wir von Freunden sie sind aber
glaube ich auch bekannt dass sie
Freundinnen mehr oder weniger als ihr
Hobby betrachten
ich glaube jeder Junggeselle in meinem
Alter hat ein bisschen dieses Hobby nur
hat er nicht gleich das Pech dass das
jedes mal in der Zeitung steht
Gunter Sachs zeigt der Welt einen völlig
neuen Typus des deutschen er prägt das
Lebensgefühl einer ganzen Generation
er ist das Gegenteil des langweiligen
lustfeindlichen und autoritätshörigen
Spießers und gerade die Franzosen lernen
nur wenige Jahre nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg das deutsche auch anders sein
können
er war dann ein toller Botschafter für
Deutschland ohne es zu wollen ja aber er
wurde zu dem und hatte dann natürlich
einen hat zu leben wovon vielen Leuten
viele Leute davon träumten
wie alle in der Familie Opel ist Gunter
Sachs ein begeisterter Sportler in St
Moritz wird mit er sich seiner
Leidenschaft im Wintersport
[Musik]
dort trifft er auch seine
opel-verwandtschaft wie seinen Onkel
Georg Georg von Opel war 17 Jahre alt
als das Werk 1929 verkauft wurde
als Opel fühlt er sich der Tradition
jedoch verpflichtet und gründet ein
Autohaus wenn er die Opel Autos schon
nicht bauen kann dann will er sie
zumindest verkaufen
das Geschäft ist sehr erfolgreich da die
Opel Autos in den 50er Jahren einen sehr
guten Ruf haben aber der Erfolg füllt
ihn nicht aus
er ist einsam wenn er abends nach Hause
kommt wartet niemand auf ihn
[Musik]
1938 hatte er zwar geheiratet doch die
Ehe ist in den 50er Jahren bereits
gescheitert er sucht Herausforderungen
und reist viel in Ostafrika besteigt er
den Kilimandscharo
er verliebt sich in das Land die
Menschen und die Tiere und kommt auf
eine Idee
dann kam das Bedürfnis eben wilde Tiere
dann auch im Gehege
zu halten und naja es muss ja schon was
besonderes sein und es war eben dann die
Elefanten und dann kommt Anfang 50er
Jahre dann die ersten drei ersten zwei
oder drei Elefanten in Hohenberg an zum
Erstaunen aller Kronberger und
Königsteiner
eine Sensation im Taunus der erste
elefantentransport
Georg hält die Tiere direkt neben seinem
Wohnhaus sehr zur Freude der Nachbarn
und seiner Söhne Heinz und Carlo
immer mehr Tiere kommen hinzu
[Musik]
der einzige privat so Deutschlands
entsteht
[Musik]
doch glücklich ist Georg von Opel nicht
er war ein
starker Typ
schwach vielleicht eben in dieser
privaten familiären Seite ich glaube das
ist ganz schwierig in der dritten
Generation aus so einer Familie
herauszukommen sich zu orientieren was
mache ich zu glauben man ist auf der
Schiene und dann privat auch noch Glück
zu haben das also er war ein ständig
Suchender Mensch der
große Bedürfnisse an Familien sind und
Wärme Harmonie hatte
doch dann erfüllt sich sein sehnlichster
Wunsch 1957 heiratet er eher eine
39-jährige Kolumbianerin
[Musik]
sie teilt seine Vorliebe für exotische
Tiere
[Musik]
und sie liebt seinen Humor
das war wohl eine
Liebesbeziehung eine Liebesheirat und
offensichtlich eine sehr glückliche Zeit
weil sie in der Zeit meinem Großvater
viel Ruhe brachte er hat zu sich
gefunden allerdings
Eugenia wie man sagt aus Kolumbien hatte
eine Schwester die wiederum mit dem
großen antipoten Fritz ja
liiert war
Fritz von Opel und seine Frau emidam die
Schwester von ihr
zwar hatte Georg seine Frau über Fritz
kennengelernt doch das versöhnte die
beiden Cousins auch nicht wieder
Fritz von Opel hat den Verkauf der Firma
nie verkraftet der sah den verändert er
wurde depressiv und unberechenbar
sein Umfeld fürchtete seine cholerischen
Anfälle es wurde sehr viel in der
Familie über ihn gesprochen und es gab
dort
in der Familie oft größere Querelen ja
die mit Fritz zu tun hatten ich weiß da
auch dass er ein
übermäßig streng mit seinen Kindern
waren die fast regelrecht darunter
litten und eine richtige Angst hatten ja
vor dem vor ihrem Vater
Fritz hat zwei Kinder Regie und
Christina genannt Putzi vor allem die
kleine Tochter leidet unter ihrem Vater
er stellt es zweijährige Kind Minuten
lang unter die eiskalte Dusche weil sie
keinen Seemannsknoten hinbekommen
sperrte sie für Stunden in die Kajüte
seiner Yacht ein allein manchmal
verprügelt er seine Tochter so sehr dass
die Schläge tagelang mit Puder behandelt
werden müssen er nennt das Erziehung
Liebe bekommt sie nur von Onkel Georg
[Musik]
das Mädchen hängt auch sehr an neochemia
ihrer Lieblingstante beide geben dem
heranwachsenden Kind halt und machen oft
mit putzige gemeinsam Urlaub
es ist der 11 märz 1964 als Putzi ihre
Tante eochenia bittet mit dem Auto in
ein besseres Skigebiet zu fahren wo noch
mehr Schnee liegt
irgendwo mit dem Auto hinfahren das was
ihre Vorfahren einst erst möglich
gemacht haben wird Ihnen jetzt zum Fluch
während der eochinger stirbt
Putzi kommt schwer verletzt ins
Krankenhaus
Fritz von Opel alt sofort an das Bett
seines Kindes und sagt nur drei Sätze
du bist schuld dass deine Tante tot ist
nur weil du woanders Skifahren wolltest
du hast sie getötet
diese Worte brechen den Lebenswillen des
jungen Mädchens die Schuldgefühle wird
Putin nie los
auch ihr Onkel Georg wird in tragischen
Unfall nie verwendeten
boah das war ein enormer Verlust das hat
ihn richtig reingerissen in eine
Depression in Gräben wo er sich neu
definieren musste wo er sein Bild von
Familie Harmonie Wärme Zärtlichkeit neu
wieder instand setzen musste wollte
jemand der Lehre nicht ertragen wollte
deswegen heiratete er ein drittes Mal
die 30 Jahre jüngere Siegrid die Ehe
verläuft nicht glücklich doch sie macht
ihn noch einmal zum Vater
[Musik]
1968 wird Gregor geboren ich habe leider
gar keine Erinnerung aber da so viele
Mitmenschen
mir berichtet haben glaube ich ein ganz
gutes Bild haben zu können von ihm
aber eigene Erinnerung ist mit drei
natürlich auch was nicht möglich
Georg von Opel findet seinen Glück nicht
mehr
1971 nur sieben Jahre nach dem
tragischen Unfall seiner Ex-Frau
verunglückt er in seinem Auto
er hatte ein Herzinfarkt das ist die
Todesursache als Bild habe ich aber
immer so gerne in Erinnerung dass er
auch am gebrochenen Herzen starb das was
das Leben eben so mit sich brachte mit
der ganzen Geschichte von Opel die in
ihm in besonderem Maße verkörpert wurde
als einer der letzten großen Opels die
dann einsam gegen ein Zaun fuhren
im gleichen Jahr stirbt auch Fritz von
Opel der alte Konkurrent von Georg
seine Tochter Putzi hatte da schon
längst mit der Familie gebrochen
es ist schade also ausgegangen ist das
hätte nicht sein müssen denn sie war ein
sehr befähigt
[Musik]
sehr begabte Frau
bei Alkohol und Drogen sucht Putzi
Ersatz für Geborgenheit ohne
Schulabschluss ohne Beruf aber mit viel
Geld und falschen Freunden sie wird
selbst Mutter ungewollt doch das Kind
hindert sie nicht am Leben eines wilden
Party Girls
[Musik]
in San tropez will sie ein unbeschwertes
Luxusleben führen mit sechs Freunden
doch das Paradies wird zur Hölle
im Sommer 77 findet die Polizei in ihrem
Haus
1,8 Tonnen Haschisch im Wert von 8
Millionen D-Mark ihre Freunde hatten die
Drogen besorgt und sie wird verhaftet
[Musik]
wie die Sache passiert war war ich in
San tropez auch und ich weiß noch ich
kann man morgen in meinen übliches Café
wo ich meine Zeitung kaufte und meinen
kaffeetrank und die waren ganz erstaunt
dass ich da war weil die haben gedacht
ich wäre auch festgenommen worden ja und
damals war das ganz klar da sind glaube
ich sechs Personen festgenommen worden
aber alle sprachen nur
Lafer Opel
Putzi steht allein im Fokus und zahlt
einen hohen Preis für Reichtum und den
bekannten Namen ihr Cousin Gunter Sachs
bleibt an ihrer Seite und für die Hälfte
es kommt zur Verhandlung
1979 wird sie zu zehn Jahren Gefängnis
verurteilt das französische Gericht
wollte ein Exempel statuieren so glaubt
die Familie bis heute
wir haben das als tragöde gesehen weil
wir wussten dass sie in falsche Kreise
gekommen war und eigentlich nicht die
treibende Kraft in der Sache war dass
sie
nur benutzt wurde und dafür so lange ins
Gefängnis musste wir fanden das richtig
wir fahren das überzogen ungerecht
doch nach drei Jahren wird sie wegen
ihrer kleinen Tochter freigelassen der
französische Staat gibt dir eine zweite
Chance und die nutzt sie
[Musik]
sie will ihrer Tochter eine bessere
Kindheit schenken als sie sie selbst
hatte
über die Zeit im Gefängnis schweigt sie
das war schon sehr sehr schlimm für Sie
da hat sie ganz drüber sprechen wollen
so schlimm war das für sie das hat sie
wollte
auf ihrer Tochter das hat sie versteckt
jedes Familienmitglied hat seine Art mit
der schicksalhaften Familiengeschichte
umzugehen
Gregor von Opel hat seinen Vater nie
richtig kennengelernt und fühlt sich
trotzdem dessen Erbe verpflichtet
[Musik]
heute lebt er im Haus seines Vaters im
Taunus
[Musik]
was Georg von Opel Ernst anfing das will
der Sohn weiterführen
[Musik]
als er volljährig wurde übernahm er das
Autohaus des Vaters
mir hat das von Anfang an Spaß gemacht
mit dem Auto was zu tun zu haben und ich
habe es als Herausforderungen gesehen
und ich wollte das Erbe weiterführen das
war das war meine Motivation
im Zuge der Opel-Krise verkaufte er das
Autohaus 2006 aus wirtschaftlichen
Gründen er ist der letzte Opel der
direkt etwas mit Autos zu tun hatte mit
ihm ging eine lange Tradition zu Ende
und es hat nicht so wie geplant
funktioniert und deswegen kann ich mich
im Spiegel schauen und sagen du hast
versucht aber das Geschäft war nicht das
was du gedacht hast was es wäre
doch der Vater hat ihm noch etwas
anderes hinterlassen Max das Nilpferd
Zahnschmerzen noch heute lebt es direkt
am Haus der Opels zusammen mit 1500
weiteren Tieren
Gregor von Opel hat den Tierpark des
Vaters zu einem der erfolgreichsten Zoos
Deutschlands aufgebaut
jährlich kommen rund 600.000 Besucher
zur Anlage es ist in die Tradition des
Vaters der hier ja ein ganzes Stück
Herzblut reingesteckt hat und etwas
Einmaliges geschaffen hat das
muss nicht nur halten werden das muss
auch ausgebaut werden einen anderen Weg
ist sein Bruder Carlo gegangen er hat
mit der Tradition der Opels gebrochen
ausgerechnet er der Nachfahrer der
autopioniere ist wieder beim Pferd
gelandet
[Musik]
auf seinem Gestüt Peters au wird mit er
sich ganz den Vierbeinern
das Pferd zieht er dem Auto vor der weiß
lebt
er kann mir fährt erleben er kann mit
dem Pferd arbeiten kann mir etwas tun
ist halt in Lebewesen
ist ja nur Pech da muss man sich dran
denken
das Auto allein kannst nicht sein es
gibt ja noch eine andere Welt neben dem
Auto und das war eben dann
die Welt mit einem PS
[Musik]
die Welt mit mehreren PS bestimmte
Jahrzehnte lang das Leben der Opels ihr
Pioniergeist machte sie reich stellte
sie aber auch vor Herausforderungen die
die Familie im zweiten
im Mausoleum in Rüsselsheim liegen alle
Opels vereint
der Stammvater Adam Opel wäre es nach
ihm gegangen hätte die Familie nie ein
Auto gebaut
sein Sohn Wilhelm der ein Imperium
aufbaute und das Leben der Familie
veränderte dessen Tochter Ellinor die
sich den Nazis verweigerte
ihr Bruder Fritz
und sein ewiger Konkurrent sein Cousin
Georg
die heutigen Opels sind mit dem Erbe
ihrer Vorfahren im rheinen
es war sicherlich mehr Segen als Unglück
würde ich sagen denn immerhin sind wir
jetzt in der vierten Generation bin ich
meine Kinder sind in der fünften
Generation und fühlen sich noch im
Herzen sehr mit Opel verbunden fühl mich
sogar noch als Opel man ist aus diesem
Humus aus dieser familienerde
aufgewachsen man ist
immer vertraut gewesen mit der ganzen
Historie wie ist das überhaupt dazu
gekommen weil es ja auch ein Teil von
einem selbst ist
der Großvater die Großmutter und so
weiter
[Musik]